- All right, everybody.
The show's almost over, but we
have time for one more play.
Get it?
Do you like the reference?
It's 'cause I make references like that
'cause I have Sports Emmys.
I don't know if I have
mentioned it this show
but I have two sports emmys
and Troy Aikman has none.
This is what I'm liking!
(upbeat music)
(Kelly laughs)
All right, I'm just kidding.
I love you, Troy.
There's nothing like making
that game winning play,
16-year-old, Jurrion knows
that as well as any athlete
and when he caught a Hail Mary pass
with just five seconds left on
the clock, it's like a movie.
He knew exactly who he
wanted to celebrate with,
check this out.
- [Narrator] Five seconds left.
QB said everyone go
deep and this happened.
(distorted sound)
(everyone cheering)
Went straight to moms.
(audience clapping)
- Every time.
Every time I cry.
It's like, where's he going?
And then he goes to his mom, I love...
He went straight to his mom
and it's the sweetest thing
ever.
We have Jurrion and his mom
Shirri on the line right now.
What's up, y'all?
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
Oh my gosh, I can't even tell you
that breaks my heart in the
best way is, first of all,
Jurrion, how did it
feel to catch that pass?
(Shirri laughs)
- It felt amazing.
And the experience, was dope.
- Oh my God, I can only imagine.
I would be freaking out,
but cool, I'll take dope.
(laughs) So, Shirri, what
did you say to Jurrion,
like before that huge play?
- Right before that play,
Jurrion was very frustrated
and so I told him that,
Jurrion, you have to connect
your heart and your mind
and his heart is God
and his mind is him and Jurrion
is the youngest of three
and I call him my miracle child
and that's because that when
Jurrion had torn his meniscus
and that's when we found out
that he had an abnormal meniscus
and he was 14 years old,
he had surgery and the
doctors then told him
that he wouldn't probably
play football anymore
and it had broken him.
And now he's in high school, junior-
- Aw.
(Shirri chuckles)
- With 21 football scholarship offers.
- Oh my gosh!
- Very proud
that that pass, it was beautiful.
I was so excited and I just
pray that he fulfill his dreams
and to be able to play in the NFL.
- Oh my gosh!
(audience clapping)
All right, I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheering)
And that's not all,
our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson
Show", want to celebrate
those creating fearlessly, just like you.
So they're gon' give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Wow.
Thank you.
- Thank you.